i think i probably would have been about
eight years old i think that's when the
first one came out
oh wrong emma oh
um as emma watson was discussing being
cast as hermione granger during hbo
max's reunion special harry potter 20th
anniversary returned to hogwarts this
photo of a little girl wearing large
minnie mouse ears flashed on screen and
fans were quick to notice that the
adorable shot which is supposed to be of
emma watson
is actually a childhood photo of actress
emma roberts granted the two emmas may
favor one another
yeah definitely
an eagle-eyed fan dug up the receipts
and found that emma roberts posted the
throwback photo on instagram in february
of 2012
captioning it quote minnie mouse ears
now the producers for the reunion
special are chiming in on the mishap
they admitted to the mistake in a
statement to entertainment weekly saying
quote well spotted harry potter fans you
brought an editing mistake of a
mislabeled photograph to our attention
new version up shortly i couldn't really
pretend
that it wasn't going to be a big deal
neither emma watson or emma roberts have
commented on the mistake but emma watson
did share her own throwback after the
special's release the 31 year old posted
a pic of herself and co-star daniel
radcliffe cuddled together during the
making of what appears to be the seventh
film harry potter and the deathly
hallows part one she captioned the photo
quote 20 years hashtag return to
hogwarts emma and i have always
loved each other really i walked into
the room where we were having tutoring
and i just don't know how to say it i
just fell in love with him also during
the special emma watson and tom felton
finally addressed their rumored romance
something harry potter fans have been
standing for years i think i was in the
hair makeup chat
and someone said something along the
lines of yeah she had a crush on you i
used to come in every day and look for
his number on the call she was number
seven
and if it if if his number was on the
call she it was
an extra exciting day emma even shared
the moment she quote fell in love with
tom i walked into the room where we were
having tutoring the assignment that had
been given was to draw what you thought
god looked like and tom had drawn a girl
with a backward cap
on a skateboard
and i just don't know how to say it i
just fell in love with him cute right
but did their relationship ever blossom
into something more than friends
here's what emma had to say nothing has
ever ever ever ever happened
romantically with us we just love each
other
that's all i can say about that
following years of romance speculation
they both explained this close
connection stayed platonic which is
something tom also opened up to e.t
about last year i think she's fantastic
and hopefully she
returns the compliment but um
as far as the romantic side of it i
think that's a slytherin gryffindor uh
thing rather than a tom and emma thing
but um i i absolutely think the world of
her and i think um
i think being
part of what we've all been part of but
for her to be kind of the only
girl certainly the youngest one on set
to grow up with what she had to grow up
with was was incredibly exciting and uh
listen you're gonna get me teary now
[Music]